(uplifting instrumental music)
- Alan Croyd was a devoted
husband, friend to many,
and of course, a loving father.
Now, to say a few words
about his rich life,
his eldest son, Anderson Croyd.
- Dude, you're up.
- Oh, right, right.
Fucking sucks, am I right?
Alright, I wrote this shit out, so,
alright, here we go.
So, picture this, right?
I'm just napping, right?
Just enjoying peaceful siesta, you know?
And then, my sister calls
me and fucking sucker punch,
gives me the news, and, it's so crazy
that he died in a car accident,
because earlier this week,
my fucking girlfriend
died in a car accident,
so, my first thought is like, oh, fuck!
Two in one week, you know?
Like, bummer city.
Bummer city, population,
my loved ones, you know?
Like, what the fuck?
Tch, tch, tch, tch, tch.
But then, I was like,
no, dude, gotta text mom.
'Cause if I'm bummed, then
she's gonna be fucking
fucked in the mind, you know?
'Cause like, my dad was her husband.
And I can say this, because he's my dad.
And I knew him.
But like, he had a nice dick, you know?
Like I saw that shit when I was like 10,
and it was fucking rad, you know?
Like, not big, you know?
Just...
Choice.
- Nice, dude.
- Thanks, dude.
Oh, and like, fuck me.
Huge, special thanks to my
buddy Zac for coming out.
'Cause, when you're going
through a hard shit, it's just,
it's just nice to have a friend.
Alright, so that's it
for me, I'm out, peace!
(microphone squeals)
(laughs)
- Thank--
(microphone squeals)
- Holy shit, dude!
- Fuck, fuck!
- Burn!
Yeah, I'm just pursuing
the acting thing right now,
super inspired by the work
of Dwayne The Rock Johnson
and Sarah Jessica Parker.
- Wow, that's so brave.
I'm not confident or pretty
enough to be an actress.
- Fuck you, yeah you are.
- Dude, can I fucking
talk to you for a second?
- Anderson, I'm right in
the middle of something.
Some pussy!
- Yeah dude, that's what I
have to talk to you about.
Excuse me!
Come on, dude.
Dude, that's my fucking sister, dude.
- What?
Oh shit, are you, I had no idea!
- Dude, she gave a eulogy
in front of you, dude!
- I was playing Doodle Jump,
dude, I'm sorry, I'll back off!
- No, no, dude, you have
my blessing or whatever,
do what you want, I just
need to warn you, dude.
I know she's playing all cute
and sweet with you right now,
but she's a fucking predator, dude.
She's been with like 10,000 guys.
She's like a cute little Wilt Chamberlain.
- Oh shit, dude, fuck that,
I'll throw in the towel
right now!
- No, dude.
It's way late in the
game for you to get out.
She's not exactly cool with
people saying no to her.
- Zac, come hang out with me!
- Caroline, I'm talking to my friend,
can you just give me like a minute!
- Please hurry!
- 'Kay, I guess I gotta go!
- Yeah.
Hey, dude.
Look.
I just wanna say, what
I said in the eulogy,
it's fucking legit, dude.
When shit goes down, you're
like my fucking parachute.
- Shut up.
(sad piano music)
(glass shatters)
- [Zac] Alright, dude, I'm off.
- Have fun, dude.
Have fun with my sister.
- You left me standing
here by myself for so long!
- Oh.
- It's okay, I'll let
you make it up to me.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Um.
Like it?
Subscribe.
Comment.
- Yeah, dude, leave a comment
in the comment section,
'cause, you never know
when you might not get to.
- Leave a comment where you
tell a loved one that you care.
Oh, and share on Facebook!
- Oh, fuck yeah.
- Yeah, dude.
'Cause then, all your
friends will get to see,
and they'll be like,
"Oh, dude, this guy's got
"fucking good taste in comedy, dude!"
(baby crying)